mais eux ils chargeaient c'était en 2005
en italie dans la vallée de suse
ces manifestants qui se frottent forces
de l'ordre on les appelle les notables
notamment en italien pour tgv non merci
leur cible le projet de ligne à grande
vitesse transalpin qui doit relier lyon
à turin
un chantier gigantesque qui prévoit la
construction d'un long tunnel à travers
les alpes dans les années 90 quand
débutent les travaux préparatoires celle
enthousiasme qui prédomine dans quelques
années ici sous la montagne un tunnel
ferroviaire de 54 km sera creusé avec au
goût d'italie au niveau de l'ampleur du
chantier on peut le comparer avec le
tunnel sous la manche par contre la
nature des roches et la nature des
travaux sera sera différemment cette
liaison reliera lyon à turin en une
heure trente au lieu de 4 heures
actuellement
mais ses promoteurs insiste avant tout
sur l'aspect écologique la future ligne
sera conçu pour le ferroutage c'est à
dire le transport de camions sur des
trains spéciaux
une technique ancienne expérimenté en
france dans les années 50 un compromis
mettra-t-il fin à la rivalité
traditionnelle du rail et de la rue un
public de techniciens assister à la
présentation de nouveaux wagons
surbaissé destinés au transport des
poids lourds et des semis roman
l'avantagent du ferroutage réduire le
nombre de camions qui transitent par la
vallée de la maurienne et asphyxient les
villages alpins en 1999 ses habitants
criel ras-le-bol l'an dernier ce sont un
million quatre cent mille camions qui
ont emprunté par la route
le tunnel du mont blanc où le tunnel du
fréjus alors la france et l'italie
signent l'accord du lyon turin en 2001
et les ministres des transports attaque
la montagne marteau piqueur en 2002
c'est la joie mais côté piémont
la résistance au projet s'organise ce
projet mécontente les élus les
écologistes du piémont ils craignent l
afflux de camions dans la région ils
l'ont fait savoir ce matin
en 2005 des dizaines de milliers de
manifestants défilent dans la vallée de
suse le lyon turin
ils n'en veulent pas ici en val de suse
il ya des filion d'amiante d'uranium
et puis la vallée déjà sillonné par une
autoroute nationale une voie ferrée
internationale
on entend que voulez-vous que nous à
part une nouvelle voie par de nouveaux
soucis de santé